Musik Podcast UFO und mit Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO. Florentin ist auf Tour, Stefan ist zuhause geblieben, alleine zurück im leeren Köln, weil alle auf Tour sind gerade. Wie geht's dir denn da? Das ist das große Florentins Tour-Tagebuch. Ja, Nummer eins. Ich glaube, wir werden es noch ein paar Mal so aufnehmen müssen. Oh, ich hasse es jetzt schon. Das ist heute die Apparatfolge, die Apparello-Folge, denn wir sind per Telefonapparat einander zugestellt. Wir haben eine lange Leitung gelegt. Ich bin gerade in Berlin. Berlin! Ich bin vor dem Columbia-Theater und im Tourbus gerade. Ich bin gerade in der Lounge des Tourbusses, also ich bin sehr entspannt, ganz viele Kissen um mich herum, ich liege flach. Und tausend Leute hören dir zu gerade. Im Grunde, ja, und ihr hört wahrscheinlich auch so ein ganz angenehmes Brummen der ganzen Technik hier im Hintergrund. Das ist der Busfahrer, ach so. Ja, bist du ein Betrüger eigentlich? Hast du einen Drang zum Betrügen? Was? Nein, warum? Was sprichst du an? Sprichst du auf die Geldsumme, die du, also, nee. Nee, generell, ich würde dich einfach nur ein bisschen besser kennen. Nee, jetzt mal ganz allgemein. Also ganz allgemein. Nee, allgemein nicht, würde ich sagen. Ich habe mir letztens überlegt, wenn ich eine Leiche finden würde, ob ich der Geld klauen würde. Oder nicht. Auf jeden Fall. Was soll die Leiche damit machen? Ja, es stimmt, guter Punkt,
aber auf der anderen Seite dachte ich mir,
ich habe genug Medical Detectives,
CSI, irgendwas
angeschaut, um zu wissen, dass sie dann Spuren
nehmen und so. Und dann ist so, ja, entschuldigen Sie,
Herr Will, bei dem Mordopfer
hier, da haben wir jetzt ihre Fingerabdrücke an der
Jackentasche und am Geldbeutel gefunden.
Bäh, das
ist jetzt aber völlig ungewöhnlich. Ich habe die Leiche nur gefunden, und schon hast du verloren. Weil die sind sehr faul, und dann bist du mordverdächtig. Weil wenn du genug Medical Detectives Folgen geschaut hast, dann weisst du, dass der, der das Portemonnaie aus der Leiche geklaut hat, niemals der ist, der auch am Ende der Mörder war. Weil natürlich wollen die am Anfang so ein bisschen verwirren und Spuren verwirren und gucken. Und immer die, die die grössten Motive haben, waren es nie. Es waren immer die, so nach dem Motto, es stimmt ja schon, es war immer der Gärtner, es war immer halt einer im Umfeld, den man früh kennengelernt hat, der eigentlich sympathisch war, der oft ein weirdes, nichtiges Motiv hat. Und es war selten der, der das Portemonnaie leicht geklalaut hat. Das stimmt, der perfekte Mord ist eigentlich, der Ablenkungsverdächtige zu sein, der dramaturgisch gebraucht wird, um die Folge spannend zu machen. Der muss man eigentlich sein. Wo immer am Anfang die erste Hälfte der Folge, bist du der Verdächtige, aber dann heißt es, nee, irgendwie passt das nicht zusammen, weil wir haben jetzt die Fingerabdrücke nochmal gezählt und der müsste irgendwie 30 Finger haben oder so und sie haben ja nur zehn und deswegen sind sie frei und dann uuuh und dann kommt doch jemand. Das muss so nervig sein, wenn man eine Leiche findet mit zehn Fingerabdrücken und man denkt, oh, es könnte jeder sein. Ja, scheiße. Alle Menschen haben zehn, das hat uns nicht weitergeholfen, genau gar nicht. Holt mir mal alle Leute aus der Umgebung von L.A. zusammen, die zehn Finger haben, okay? Oh Mann. Nicht mehr, nicht weniger, exakt zehn. Okay, Boss. Mr. Rogers, alle haben zehn Finger. Lacher, Lachtrack. Wirklich alle? Und dann sehen wir so ein Flashback, wie in seiner Jugend er einen Finger verloren hat, weil er seine Mutter aus dem trinkenden Auto retten musste. Detectives haben immer dramaturgische Backstories. Und wie in seiner Klasse alle nur neun Finger hatten. Und er in so einer Welt aufgewachsen ist, wo er dachte, alle haben neun Finger. Und er ist von der Information wirklich überrascht, ernsthaft überrascht. Wie alle haben zehn Finger? Weil er es nicht wusste. Weil er sein Leben lang so aufgewachsen ist und dachte, die Neunies wären normal. Es läuft so ein Bewerbungsgespräch bei der Kripo ab, dass man sagt, haben Sie ein Alkoholproblem?
Nee.
Okay, würden Sie ja auch Ihr Privatleben opfern und Ihre Ehe in Gefahr bringen, um den letzten Fall zu lösen? Letzte Frage, haben Sie einen beigen Trenchcoat? Nein, raus! Raus! Die haben meine Zeit vertrödelt. Aber auch immer und den Krawattenknoten immer zu lose. Und so Haare, die so strähnig ins Gesicht liegen. Diese Haare. Ich habe damals ein geiles Nintendo DS Spiel gehabt. Das hieß Hotel Dusk Room und dann halt eine dreistellige Zahl, die ein bisschen mysteriös klingt. Und das war so toll. Da war es nämlich genau dieser Klischee der Detective, der eine Nacht im Hotel eingecheckt hat. Und das war wirklich toll. Und der hatte auch immer so eine geile, strähnige Frisur und so einen geilen Taschen, so einen Rasierer, so einen elektrischen Rasierer. Und ich wollte damals als Kind immer schon diesen alten Aktenkoffer haben und diesen Rasierer. Und meine Eltern mussten auch gedacht haben, was wir begegnen haben mit unserem Sohn durch die Stadt und versuchen, einen alten Aktenkoffer und einen elektrischen Rasierer zu kaufen, weil ich so in diesem Spiel war. Ich wollte diese Person werden. War halt aber zwölf. Ich finde aber diese ganze Thematik Kriminalromane und tatsächliche Kriminalarbeit sehr spannend. Ich habe mal irgendwie gehört, dass es so, wenn so neue Kriminaltechniken entwickelt werden, irgendwie so neue Fahndungsmethoden oder neue DNA-Methoden,
dass es dann immer so für Autoren so ein spezielles Meeting gibt, wo die denen das sagen, dass die das in ihre Romane einbauen können. So ein bisschen so eine Schnittstelle zwischen den Romanautoren und der tatsächlichen Polizei, weil das ja nicht komplett an die Öffentlichkeit gehen soll, aber die das irgendwie schon vorab wissen. Ich frage mich aber, ob es nicht auch andersrum ist, dass wenn jemand jetzt einen Roman schreibt, der einfach zu gut ist, wo wirklich der perfekte Mord genau geschildert wird und die Polizei sagt so, okay, okay, lassen wir, Mr. Grisham, okay, chill, okay, sorry, wir sind auf derselben Seite irgendwo, also ich meine, was soll das, lassen Sie es mal bitte und dann sagt, okay, lassen. Bauen wir noch einen dummen Fehler ein, dummen Bruder.
Warum gibt es das nicht für andere Genres?
Also warum gibt es nicht für Comedy-Autoren so eine Schnittstelle, die anruft und sagt,
wisst ihr, was jetzt gerade total lustig ist? Zu grosse Schuhe.
So riesige Schuhe und die nur so Knatschgeräusche machen, wenn man läuft.
Das bitte in den nächsten Roman einbauen. Wie dankbar ich da wäre,
dass man mal so ein bisschen am Puls der Zeit gebracht wird.
Ich erinnere mich, als Stromberg noch regelmäßig lief, hat Ralf Hussmann auch einen Aufruf gestartet an Büroarbeiter, dass die irgendwie so Sachen einschicken sollen wie so Flyer für Motivationstrainings oder so, halt so ganz elendig langweilige, drepionierende Sachen aus dem Büroalltag, damit er das verbauen kann. Wo auch man sich zusammensetzt und so ein Personalleiter sitzt dann da und naja gut und dann irgendwie Freitagnachmittag kommen wir noch mal alle rein für ein Feedback-Gespräch und Ralfussmann so, ha ha ha, geil, das ist geil, das ist richtig geil, okay weiter, weiter, weiter und dann trinkt ihr Kaffee oder was und dann ja Kaffee, jeder kriegt ein, das ist okay, mega gut, mega gut, dann schreibt sich alles auf. Es passt nicht so richtig zu dem Ralfussmann, den ich aus Geschichten kenne. Oh, und den den persönlich kennengelernt hast. Nee, ich weiß nicht, und ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich das sagen sollte, jetzt diese Anekdote, aber ich habe gehört, dass Ralf Fussmann wenig an Input interessiert ist, und ein Schauspieler, der immer häufig mit ihm zusammengearbeitet hat, ist zu ihm hingegangen und hat gesagt, ja, ich habe hier noch ein paar Ideen für meine Figur, und er hat gesagt, oh, okay, einen Moment kurz, ich muss kurz kurz raus. Dann ist er rausgegangen, wie man das aus den Simpsons kennt, hat sein Auto angemacht und ist weggefahren. Und ist erst eine Woche später wiedergekommen. Er hat's einfach durchgezogen. Das fand ich so toll, dass man das so lebt. Einfach dieses Nee, ich will nichts von euch hören. Ich hab gehört, dass Ralf Hussmann sehr an Input interessiert ist, vor allem wenn er von Ricky Gervais kommt. Okay, okay, burned! Ach, na ja. Kurz mal, Gegendarstellung, also wir müssen heute ein paar Sachen abarbeiten. Wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, es war die letzte Folge von Alf, aber das war nur das Teasing auf den Film, der danach kam. Dankeschön für eure Postkarten, ich weiß nicht, wo man noch Postkarten kaufen kann, Dankeschön für eure Teletextnachrichten, ich hab's mitgekriegt, es stört mich selber. Es war nur das Teasing für den schlechten Alffilm. Ich finde trotzdem, dass es das nach wie vor zur lustigen Geschichte macht, weil die Sitcom halt so endet. Naja. Es gibt ja so ... Manchmal gibt's ja so Videos von Tieren, die kurz vor Erdbeben dann irgendwie so ganz aufgeregt sind, und man hat das Gefühl, die wittern das, lange bevor die Menschen es wittern. Ich glaub, ich habe eine ähnliche Fähigkeit. Und sorry, Murmeltiere sind immer aufgeregt? Ja, das stimmt. Und man denkt sich so, ist das jetzt ernst oder nicht oder was, Murmi, was ist los? Aber das ist ihr Leben, das ist ihr Leben. Murmeltiere sind immer so ein constant, äh, äh, was war da drüben? Was war da drüben? Keine Ahnung. Da ist die Erdbebenreichweite einfach zu hoch, die spüren jedes Erdbeben aus der ganzen Erde. Und immer so, oh, oh, ah ne, war in Singapur, oh, oh, Bangladesch, okay, egal. Die spüren jeden Tod eines Menschen die ganze Zeit und sind konstant. Ich glaube, Eulen tun das, deswegen haben die diesen, kommen die mich besorgten Blick. Die sind einfach zu sensibel und die machen immer, uh, wenn einer stirbt, uh, uh. Ich hab was, ich war ja in Wien und ich war im Kunsthistorischen Museum in Wien und da gab es die Wes Anderson Ausstellung, da gab es ein total cooles Buch, war der ausgestellt, so ein altes Lexikon, aber so zu einer Zeit, wo die noch nicht so richtig viel über Tiere wussten und es gibt so einen geilen Eintrag, also erstmal dieses Buch ist total cool, weil links quasi, wenn du eine Seite aufschlägst, eine Doppelseite, ist links immer ein selbst gemaltes Bild von Eulen in dem Fall, also von dem Tier, was gerade beschrieben wird, und rechts ist so ein, ja sag ich mal, improvisierter Eintrag, wo man nicht so viel weiß. Ich muss es vorlesen, aber es ist schwer zu lesen, deswegen stotter ich wahrscheinlich, weil es halt in so einer alten Schrift geschrieben ist. Aber man merkt so, heutzutage weiss man mehr über Eulen. Das ist vor zweieinhalb Jahren oder so gewesen. Also, die Eulen sind bekanntlich Raubvögel, die nur des Nachts bei Monden scheine und in der Abend- oder aber auch Morgendämmerung, denn in einer ganz finsteren Nacht sehen sie ebenso wenig als alle anderen Tiere auf ihren Raub ausfliegen, weil ihre grossen und sehr weit geöffneten Augen, die haben nicht grosse Augen, die sind immer sehr weit geöffnet, zu empfindlich für das Tages- und Sonnenlicht sind und gänzlich davon geblendet werden, tagsüber.
Das ist der Grund, die sind nachtsaktiv, weil sie geblendet werden in einem Tag.
Vor allem Tages- und Sonnenlicht,, dass man jetzt die beiden zusammenwirft. Sie teilen sich in zwei grosse Hauptgeschlechter ab, nämlich in die Shubu oder Ohreulen, die Federbüsche auf den Köpfen in Form von Ohren haben. Vielleicht sind es die Ohren, vielleicht sind es einfach die Ohren. Und in Eulen, die keine Federohren und nur grosse runde Köpfe haben. Runde Köpfe. Aber keine Körper, nur Köpfe. Aber sowas liest man auch neuzutage nicht. Runde Köpfe. Das klingt so wie so ein Baby, was das beschreibt. Und nicht wie ein Wissenschaftler, der gerade, also nie ein Wissenschaftler sagt das Wort Kopf, oder? Die grosse runde Köpfe haben. Jedes dieser Geschlechter hat wieder mehr Gattungen unter sich. Und dann kommt ein ganz grosser Artikel um Nummer eins, die grosse Schuhu. Naja. Die schwarze Eule ist am grössten unter allen Eulen, denn sie ist anderthalb Fußuss hoch. Oh, Fuss war damals eine Einheit? Ja. In Deutschland? Warum hat man das denn geändert? Sie wohnt in Wäldern in hohlen Bäumen, fliegt überaus leise und still und nähert sich von Feldmäusen, er nähert sich von Hamstern und kleinen Vögeln, die diese verschluckt. Sie legt Eier gerne in die Nester des Hühnerwein, der Krähen und Elstern. Ja, interessant. Es ist so ein bisschen, man weiss nicht genau, wie viele Hintergründe sind, dahinter steckt das war nicht sehr lustig. Man hat einfach einen Typen gefragt, der nah an einem Wald wohnt und so, was ist das für ein Ding? Eine Schubu. Und die haben grosse Augen, weil die haben nachher nicht ganz weit auf, damit die viel sehen. Ja, es klingt so improvisiert, Schuhu. Aber daraus wurde jetzt Uhu wahrscheinlich, weil es weniger lächerlich klingt. Aber wie albern das ist mit diesem S, mit diesem alten deutschen S, dass man das auch einfach nur einen einzigen Buchstaben geändert hat von früher. Man hat gesagt, die Sprache ist ziemlich gut, nur dieses S ist scheiße, lass uns das mal ändern. Das sieht aus wie ein F einfach. Ja, aber das ist wirklich ein Problem. Das ist wirklich ein Problem. Das ist offensichtlich, da jemand ganz kurz ist in die falsche Richtung abgebogen und dachte sich, also es gibt ja viele, beim grossen S haben sie ja alles richtig gemacht. Das grosse S ist ja von einerseits alle anderen Buchstaben, aber das kleine S ist einfach ein F ohne Strich und sieht dadurch aus, noch mehr wäre das T. Es ist einfach schlecht. Ich finde gut, dass man sich da korrigiert. Ja, ich habe aber auch dadurch einfach ein albernes Gefühl, wenn ich an alte Generationen denke. Ich habe das Gefühl, die haben immer dieses wie dieser Hund, dieser Meme-Hund, dass sie immer so mit so einem F sprechen. Ich habe Naffe Schufe die ganze Zeit immer so. Ich habe das Gefühl, die alten Generationen kommen nicht gut dabei weg. Die Filme, von denen alle zu schnell, alle Aufnahmen aus dem Ersten Weltkrieg sind alle viel zu schnell, weil die weniger Frame Rate hatten. Und die Sprache. Alles Quatsch. Du hast einfach das Gefühl, die Welt vor 1900 war einfach albern. Also auch irgendwie Krieg, Tod, aber vor allem auch einfach lächerlich. Man kann es sich ernst nehmen. Ich glaube ich glaube, Charlie Chaplin, das war ja auch ... In meinem Kopf waren die auch alle so. Die waren schneller. Sind auch so gegangen. Ja, und noch mal mit so grossen ... also viel Kniebewegung, also viel hohe Knie und dann grosse, weite Schritte. Weil man ... ich weiß nicht warum. Vor allem, warum war das so schnell? Weil die hatten noch Zeit, es gab ja nichts zu entdecken. Also es gab auch viel Langeweile, keine Handys, nicht kontinuierlich irgendwelche News. Die Welt war doch langsam, langlebiger, oder nicht? Ja, du hast den ganzen Tag nur über Eulen nachgedacht und am Ende des Tages gesagt, ja, wissen wir nicht. Vielleicht existiert die Schuhu gar nicht. Vielleicht. Aber was ich kurz sagen wollte mit den Katzen und der sensiblen Fähigkeit, ich glaube, ich habe die Fähigkeit, Fanmail vorauszusagen.
Ich habe schon damals, als wir in Berlin auf der Bühne standen und du angefangen hast mit Alf, ich habe ins Publikum geguckt, da sind so viele Augen aufgeleuchtet, so viele Hände direkt zum Kugelschreiber gezückt. Ich wusste schon, fuck da kommt was, ich habe schon dieses Geräusch gehört, wenn hundert E-Mails am gleichen Tag direkt im Moment, in dem die Show endet, hat man über ganz viel gehört. Mail-Tsunami. Wenn ich schon eine Mail lese mit dem Betreff Korrektur, direkt im Mülleimer, direkt immer dieses fucking korrigieren, ey. Kann man das nicht so einstellen? Kann man das nicht, auch wenn ich immer was bei Ebay einstelle. Ich würde gerne einstellen, dass mein Spamordner auf Begriffe wie Frage zum Produkt oder auf Korrektur oder so reagiert. Direkt einfach Spam. Oder hoher Preis, weg. Ich verkauf jetzt meine Kamera. Aber ich hab meine Kaffeemaschine verkauft, von Jahr oder so. Und dann kam die Frage, wie viele Tassen Kaffee wurden da mitgemacht? Ich denk mir, Alter, wie will ich das denn rausfinden? Und dann hat er mir geschrieben, drücken Sie dreimal auf die Kaffeetasse, dreimal auf den Espresso, dreimal auf den kleinen Kaffee und einmal auf irgendwie Entdampfen und so. Und dann kommt eine Zahl, die in binär durch das Blinken angezeigt wird. Und es war wirklich so, dreimal hat dann die grosse Kaffeetasse geblinkt, zweimal die Espresso und dann konnte ich mit binär ausrechnen, wie viele Tassen Kaffee ich gemacht habe. Und ich dachte, wir kurzen sich in so einer Parallel, also was ist noch alles möglich, wenn das möglich ist? Vorsicht, nicht zweimal Tasse und dreimal Espresso, das ist der Selbsterstörungsknopf. Zweimal beides. Ich habe so Angst vor meinem Toaster mittlerweile, weil das ist geschützt, was heiß wird in der Kaffeemaschine. Aber so ein Toaster, der kann Schaden anrichten, wenn er will. Also immer nur einmal draufdrücken, wenn es nicht klappt hat beim ersten Mal, erstmal eine halbe Stunde lang weg vom Toaster. Hast du so einen Krümelschuber bei deinem Toaster? Krümel was? Krümelschuber? So eine Krümelschublade? Oh, weiß ich gar nicht. So eine Schublade, wo unten die ganzen Krümel eingefangen werden. Das ist ganz wichtig, falls du mal wieder Schnitzel machen willst oder so. Hast du da dann ganz viele Toastkrümel? Wirklich? Ja! So werden Schnitzel gemacht? Ich glaube schon, deswegen immer so. Vor jedem Schnitzeltag müssen erstmal 10.000 Toast gemacht gemacht werden, damit man genug Toastkrümel hat. Wusstest du, dass man bei der Alufolienrolle rechts und links das reindrücken kann, damit man die besser abrollen kann? Oder bei so einer Frischhaltefolie, kannst du auch rechts und links bei diesen grossen Röhren das eindrücken, damit es einfach ... Was eindrücken? Ja, hinten die Verpackung, rechts und links. Damit du halt ... Das ist ja so eine Röhre, die da drin ist. Damit du die besser abziehen kannst, damit es wie so aufgehangen ist. Das ist ganz toll. Das ist wirklich ganz fantastisch. Man weiss viele Dinge nicht über Dinge, die man im Haushalt hat. Aber dafür sind wir ja da. Krass. Ja. So, wie gesagt, die Gegend darstellt noch nicht ... Es geht noch weiter. Und zwar, die Hauptstadt von Botswana ist nicht Ouagadougou. Ich weiß nicht, was in Berlin mit mir los war, aber ich hab so viel Quatsch erzählt. Es ist Gaborone. Ach ja. Mir lag's auch auf der Zunge. Und Gegendarstellung Nummer drei. Es kamen viele Nachrichten bei uns rein, ob wir Lacher reingeschnitten haben in die Folge.
Nein!
Doch, ja, nee, und die Antwort ist natürlich nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Es gibt einen Schnitt in der Folge, habe ich nochmal nachgeguckt, extra, es gibt einen Schnitt, ich weiß nicht genau, warum ich den gemacht habe, als ich irgendwann betrunken mitten in der Nacht diese Folge missmutig geschnitten habe, es gibt einen Schnitt, ich weiß nicht, was ich da rausgeschnitten habe, echt nicht mehr, aber wir haben natürlich keine Lacher reingeschnitten, aber diese, offensichtlich lacht einer im Publikum die ganze Zeit gleich und ich würde gerne wissen, ich fand die Vorstellung so lustig, wie wir danach da sitzen und sagen, nee, mein Gegner muss besser ankommen und Lacher reinschneiden. Ja, oder nochmal so extra so ein Fake-Publikum engagieren, dass sich dann die Folge nochmal anhört und dann immer lacht an den richtigen Stellen.
Und wir mit so einem grossen Schild lachen, grosses lachen, kleines lachen. Aber eigentlich ist es mal ein kleines Feedback für die Berlin-Crowd, die bei unserem Live-Podcast dabei war. Ihr habt ein sehr künstliches Lachen, einfach mal als Feedback auch an euch. Kleine Korrektur mal an euch, liebe Fans! Oh, du klangst gerade echt wie so eine alte Doku, so eine alten Hitler-Doku, so eine Nürnberger Prozess-Doku, so klangst du gerade. Erzähl mal ein bisschen was aus deinem Nightliner, du schläfst ja auch da. Ja, es ist ganz interessant, weil man so ein bisschen diese zwei Seiten des Rockstar-Daseins lebt, so einerseits glitzernde Kostüme, große Stadien, jubelnde Fans, Lichter, Musik, Mikrofon, aber auf der anderen Seite streiten sich dann irgendwie drei Typen in Unterhose um vier Uhr nachts um die eine Toilette, die man im Bus hat und kann nicht schlafen, während man die ganze Zeit durchgerüttelt wird. Man schläft ja auch im Bus zwischen den verschiedenen Locations. Wir fahren dann immer die Nacht durch und versuchen zu schlafen und es ist extrem unangenehm und ich kann überhaupt gar nicht schlafen und es ist sehr interessant, weil man auch, der Tag ist sehr fokussiert, weil man hat irgendwie zwei Stunden Auftritt und da ist gar nichts, überhaupt gar nichts. Und du sitzt da und du liegst da und du stellst sich hin und guckst mal nach links und guckst nach rechts. Stell sich hin? Ja, manchmal stellt man sich hin. Ist das so Tage? Aber es nimmt schon einen beträchtlichen Teil deines Tages ein, das Hinstellen, oder? Ja, ja, auf jeden Fall. Und die ersten Tage war ich noch mega produktiv, ich habe mir Bücher mitgenommen, ich habe mir Sachen mitgenommen, die ich schneiden muss und so und irgendwie hin und her und die ersten drei Tage mega produktiv, aber jetzt die letzten drei Tage einfach nur noch vegetieren, nur noch man sitzt da und starrt einfach nur auf die verschiedenen Städte, die an einem vorbeirauschen und man ist völlig desillusioniert und man weiß überhaupt nicht, wo man ist die ganze Zeit du schläfst ein und wachst an einem anderen Ort auf und es ist total merkwürdig.
Ich träume unglaublich krass,
super krasse Storys. Ich habe
von der Story geträumt, dass ich irgendwie mal,
als ich ein Kind war, aus Versehen
das Kind von meinem Nachbarn umgebracht habe
und jetzt ist der Nachbar bei mir
zu Gast und erzählt davon
und ich habe so das latente Gefühl, dass er mich umbringen will
und dann gehe ich in den Supermarkt
und dann sehe ich den Nachbarn aber an der Scheibe und es ist wirklich wie so ein ganzer Horrorfilm gewesen, wo ich die ganze Zeit das Gefühl hab, fuck, der will mich umbringen. Was mach ich jetzt, soll ich jetzt noch auf den einen reden, positiv oder so? Aber eigentlich ist es geil, wenn du dann irgendwie mit dem Rundfunk-Kreis-Orchester dann in Berlin oder Leipzig stehst und im Publikum steht dann der gleiche Typ. Ja, genau. Das ist dein Traum und startet plötzlich an aus der letzten Reihe. Oh Gott, es war die ganze Zeit Jan Delay. Und dann singst du den Mardersong und es ist lächerlich. Und dann guckst du noch mal hin und im Hintergrund ist er dann weg. Und du wachst auf und ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich wach während der Nacht ständig auf und schlafe wieder ein. Und man hat immer so diese Zwischenstadien, Zwischenschlaf und wach. Und es ist ganz merkwürdig, weil du bist wach und du denkst nach, ja fuck, soll ich jetzt mal irgendwie auf den einen reden? Ich meine, wenn der mich wirklich umbringen will, was bringt es da noch, mit dem zu reden? Und irgendwann merkst du, ich bin wach, hallo, ich schlack überhaupt nicht mehr. Es ist wirklich nichtig einfach. Ja, wenn du so anfängst, dich mit einem rationalen Bewusstsein, also lächerlich viel Gehirnkapazität, darauf zu verschwenden, was du für einen weirden Trauma hast, wo du aus Glas bist, und man sich plötzlich denkt, oh, das ist ein Problem, das ist wirklich ein Problem. Wie komme ich denn morgen da überhaupt hin, wenn ich aus Glas bin, zur Arbeit? Es ist total merkwürdig. Und dann schläfst du wieder ein und dann hast du teilweise im Traum noch bruchstückhafte Erinnerungen an den anderen Traum, aber plötzlich bist du irgendwie ein Hund im Weltraum und irgendwie überlegst dir, scheiße, ich habe das ganze Hundefutter auf der Erde vergessen, wie lange kann ich hier überleben im Space und denkst dir, wollte er mich nicht umbringen, was habe ich hier im Supermarkt gemacht und es ist alles so konfus und es wird immer konfus. Aber es ist ein cooler Hund, es ist ein cooler Hund, der sagt, wie kann ich überleben im Space, das finde ich doch nicht so schlecht, es ist ein cooler Hund. Cooler Hund. Du hast sich Träume als uncooler Hund oder was? Glaubst du, wer ich bin? Ich habe keine coolen Träume.
Ich träume meistens nur von mir, vom Tag tatsächlich. Ich verarbeite Dinge. Aber interessant, ich stelle mir das wahnsinnig gemütlich vor, in einem rappelnden Bett einzuschlafen, weil es ist doch auch das, was man kennt aus der Wiege damals. Richtig. Wenn Eltern dich schütteln, dann schlägt man doch schnell ein, oder?
Ja, das stimmt. Es ist auch so, dass es wirklich eine beruhigende Wirkung hat, wenn der Turbus sich bewegt.
Aber das Problem ist, ich werde immer nur müder, müder, müder, aber ich schlafe nicht ein.
Das Problem ist ja nicht, dass ich nicht müde bin, sondern dass ich nicht einschlafen kann.
Und dann kommst du in diese Zwischenlimbo-Phasen, dass du extrem müde bist und irgendwie
die Hälfte deines psychischen Bewusstseins hat schon
abgeschaltet, aber du schläfst nicht.
Du bist noch in so einem
Bildschirmschoner-Modus, du bist nicht aus,
aber du bist noch nicht an und dann
spacest du so in verschiedene Bewusstseinszuschneid rein.
Das ist super merkwürdig. Ich glaube aber auch,
dass dieses Wiegen auch was irgendwie
so ganz tief kindliche Traumata
aufreißt und man deswegen,
dass ich so super strange träume. Normalerweise träume ich fast nichts. Normalerweise träume ich davon und mir überlege, ah shit, wenn ich jetzt die Fanta-Flasche, die hat einen Kronkorken, wenn ich die jetzt aufmache, dann muss ich die ja schnell austrinken, weil sonst geht die ganze Kohlensäure raus. Ich habe jetzt aber nur genug Durst für eine halbe Fanta-Flasche. Soll ich dann jetzt nicht doch lieber noch warten, bis ich genug Durst habe? Und dann irgendwann wache ich auf und denke, Leute, ganz im Ernst, was war das denn? Aber auf der Tour, ich träume so krass, es ist total abgefahren. Aber liebe Geschworenen, liebe Geschworenen, am Anfang der Story hat Florentin Will gerade noch gesagt, dass er in seiner Kindheit einen Menschen umgebracht hat, seinen Nachbarn umgebracht hat. Er hat das alles als Traum abgetan. Und am Ende dieser Anekdote sagt er, oh, er ist in dieser Zwischenwelt, dieses Limbo, wie er es genannt hat, in der er Kindheitstraumata bewältigt. Keine weiteren Fragen. Ich möchte ganz kurz dazu einwenden, dass dieser Podcast vor 20 Jahren aufgenommen wurde und ich seitdem auch keinen Kontakt mehr zu Stefan Tietze habe, der diese Folgen immer sehr, sehr einseitig geschnitten hat und teilweise auch Lacher reingeschnitten hat, an völlig unsinnigen Stellen, auch an Folgen, die nicht live waren. Und deswegen möchte ich hier dieses Beweisstück nicht haben. Euer Ehren, over. Genau, over euer Ehren, sagt man glaube ich. Oder euer Ehren, over, das weiß ich nicht genau. Und nächste Woche bei Serial. Bei Serial Staffel vier. Es wird echt immer schlechter, muss man sagen. Haha, ja, stimmt, ja. Wir, Leute, finden keine fucking Stories mehr. Ich will mal eine Fiction-Folge, ich will mal eine Fiction-Folge Podcast-Ufo machen. Ja, mach mal nächste Folge. Nee, komm, da müssen wir sehr viel schreiben. Ja, schreib mal was. Ich hab Zeit. Ach ja, du hast ja Zeit. Genau, ich wollte nur noch mal sagen, wir haben keine Lacher reingeschnitten, weil das gehört sich nicht. Weil das ist eine absurde Vorstellung, dass wir da vorsitzen. Wir haben Lacher rausgeschnitten. Ja, tatsächlich haben die das bei Seinfeld immer gesagt, dass sie Lacher rausgeschnitten haben, weil die Leute zu viel gelacht haben. Die haben eine halbe Stunde am Stück gelacht, die waren völlig hysterisch. Das haben alle bestätigt, weil die halt so, und das war ja damals die grösste Sendung der Welt, so ungefähr, und du hattest halt ein riesen Star gespicktes Ensemble, und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass dann diese Leute so ein bisschen hysterisch wurden bei dieser Aufzeichnung, und am Anfang hat Jerry Seinfeld immer noch sein Stand-up gemacht, und es war ja auch immer lustig. Und dann waren die Folgen ja auch immer lustig, und das Publikum ist wohl ausgeflippt. Da gab es wohl nichts mehr. Die Stühle standen nicht mehr in einer Reihe danach. Die haben wirklich um sich geworfen mit Lachern, und am Ende haben die gesagt, das können wir alles nicht verwenden. Alle Mikrofone sind übersteuert, zwei sind kaputt, drei haben die lachend, haben die die XLR-Kabel rausgerissen, wir wissen nicht, was wir machen sollen. Und dann konnten wir es am Ende nicht verwenden und haben die Lacher rausgeschnitten. Es ist aber interessant, ich schaue bei den Auftritten oft auch das Publikum an und man merkt erstens interessanterweise, dass sich Städte stark unterscheiden und ich habe das Gefühl, dass in den Städten, in denen, sag ich mal, mehr Kulturangebot herrscht, also in denen die Bewohner wahrscheinlich häufiger auf Konzerten sind, merkt man das, weil dass die Leute auch einfach mehr, sich besser irgendwie, sich besser anpassen und irgendwie integriert sind. Und es gibt jetzt kein schlechtes Publikum und gutes Publikum, aber jetzt gerade in Berlin oder in Köln hat man schon gemerkt, da war einfach mehr Stimmung, da war mehr Party, da war mehr extrovertierte Tanzlaune. Wohingegen in den anderen Städten, die vielleicht das erste Mal in ihrem Leben auf einem Konzert waren, nicht so, das finde ich ganz interessant. Und in Wien nimmt man eben Opernglas in der Hand. Du, ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt. Ich bin drei Meter vor dir, nimm das Opernglas ab. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt.
Und es ist tatsächlich recht unangenehm. Und ich glaube, ich kann auf kein Konzert mehr gehen. Ich war nie auf vielen Konzerten und ich habe nie den Modus gefunden, wie man gut auf einem Konzert sein kann. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich mag eigentlich hauptsächlich Konzerte, wo man sich hinsetzt, wo einfach keine Erwartungshaltungen an eingestellt werden, wo man einfach da sitzt und dann guckt man zu. Und es ist so merkwürdig, weil einerseits ist es so komisch, wenn die Leute einen einfach nur anstarren, gerade wenn dann irgendwie auf der Bühne getanzt wird und alle haben Spaß und taunen und die starren dann nur so an wie Fische. Das ist komisch. Aber auf der anderen Seite können die ja auch nicht wirklich super mittanzen und gross Party machen. Das ist ganz merkwürdig. Ich habe noch nicht verstanden, wie man das richtig macht, aber sie haben ja Spaß. Fische blinzeln, ne? Doch, doch, klar. Was? Klar. Fische blinzeln. Sie müssen ja Wasser aus den Augen kriegen. Ach so, die Fische blinzeln, damit das Auge trocken bleibt. Ja, klar. Und Menschen blinzeln, damit das Auge feucht bleibt. Ja, klar. Aber es ist keine Option, dass sie nass sind. Nee, die haben ja alles andersrum. Ach ja, genau. Ach so. Haben wir schon mal über Flundern gesprochen eigentlich? Haben wir ausreichend über Flundern gesprochen? Wir haben, glaube ich, die ersten 600 Folgen ausschliesslich über Flundern gesprochen. Ja, ich will nur noch mal sagen, dass es wahnsinnig asymmetrisch ist und absurd. Ja, stimmt. Aber es wäre auch komisch, wenn es symmetrisch wäre und ein Auge die ganze Zeit auf den Boden gucken würde. Das wäre auch seltsam, weil es ist ja so auf deriter, der Fisch. Da würde ein Auge die ganze Zeit nur auf den Boden starren und das andere nach oben.
Das wäre praktisch. Ich glaube, es gibt ja so Leute mit schlechtem Rücken, die dann immer so nach vorne übergebeugt laufen und die dann immer auf den Boden gucken.
Und manchmal denke ich mir, ist nicht so dumm. Ist nicht so dumm, ständig vor sich auf den Boden zu gucken.
Man findet viel Kleingeld, man findet viele andere tolle Dinge und man kann nicht mehr stolpern, weil man die ganze Zeit vor sich auf dem Boden guckt. Ah, ist nicht das... Na ja, du stolperst doch nach vorn halt immer. Ja, aber du siehst ja, wohin du läufst. Aber du bist vor Eulen in Angriff und bist du nicht... Das stimmt, da hast du keine Chance. Da hast du überhaupt gar keine Chance. Da hast du wirklich keine Chance. Ich bin in der Stadt lang gelaufen und da war vor mir jemand mit einem Pömpel. Das war ein Mann mit einem Pömpel in der Hand. Aber er hat das nicht getragen wie jemand, der einen Pömpel trägt, sondern er hat es getragen wie so ein Zepter. Und dann neben ihm war seine Frau und dann hat er, manchmal wollte er ihr Dinge zeigen in der Stadt, und dann hat er mit dem Pömpel genommen, war sie so angestossen und hat dann auf das Gebäude gezeigt, von dem er erzählt hat. Und es war so seltsam, weil das so als Gegenstand zu nehmen, wie so ein Regierungszepter damit umherzulaufen, und er hat sich auch ein bisschen gefühlt wie so ein König. Aber ich denke mir, also was muss denn, du hast ja keinen guten Tag, wenn du dir einen Pömpel kaufen musst. kaufen muss. Es kommt darauf an, es gibt ja verschiedene Arten von Pömpelkäufen. Es gibt ja akute Pömpelkäufe und es gibt ja, sag ich mal, latente Pömpelkäufe. Oh, prophylaktische Pömpelkäufe. Richtig, wo du dann einfach sagst, in zwei, drei Wochen, ich hab's im Blut. Ich hab im Gefühl, irgendwas bahnt sich da an. Und einfach mal, ich meine, man kann sich auch mal gut irgendwie so ein schön indisches Curry und dann weiss man auch einfach genau, wollen Sie einen Pömpel dazu? Ja, nehme ich dazu und dann zack, bist du schon bereit. Ich brauche, glaube ich, noch nie einen Pömpel in meinem Leben. Ich bin mir auch nicht hundertprozentig, ich weiß auch nicht ganz genau, was die bewirken. Ich weiß nur, dass ich mit einem Pömpel mal eine Fliese rausgerissen habe aus dem Badezimmer, dass ich diesen Pömpel hatte und der war im Badezimmer und ich dachte mir, okay, und ich werfe den halt natürlich, wie man es macht, wirklich wie so ein Wurfsperr gegen die Wand, kein Problem, saugt sich da fest und ich will ihn wieder abziehen und reisse die komplette Fliese mit raus und ja, eigentlich ein geiles Foltermittel, so ein Mittelalter, so ein Pömpel aufs Gesicht und dann das Gesicht abreissen, das ganze Gesicht abreissen. Genau, und dann selber das Gesicht aufsetzen und dann als der neue König durch die Stadt gehen. Oder man kann dann Gesichter austauschen. So, face swap. Ja, finde ich nicht so schlecht, so ein bisschen impossible-mäßig. Ich glaube, die Leute im Mittelalter haben mega viel Scheisse ausprobiert und dachten sich so, oh Scheisse, ja klar klappt das nicht. Fuck, sorry, natürlich klappt es nicht, das Gesicht abzuschneiden und zwei Gesichter auszutauschen, sorry, fuck, egal, scheiß drauf, scheiß drauf, sorry, sorry, tut mir leid jetzt für euch beide, aber es ist eine super dumme Idee gewesen.
naja, vor allem die konnten ja wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse auch nicht austauschen.
Ja, total. Und heute bei uns, wenn irgendwie ein Arzt sagt, pass mal auf, wenn wir jetzt Blätter so in die Hautporen reinstecken, dann können ja der Mensch Photosynthese machen. Lass uns das mal ausprobieren. Und irgendein Arm ist schon mal ein stirbt und dann so, ja scheiss Idee, sorry, sorry, dumm gelaufen, aber dann kriegen das alle Wissenschaftler auf der Welt mit, okay, das lieber nicht machen. Wurgegen im Mittelalter musste jeder einzelne Schamane, musste jeden Scheiss selber ausprobieren. Der eine hat Aspirin hergestellt und hat halt gegen Kopfschmerzen geholfen, aber konnte halt nicht helfen, wenn da irgendwie mal wirkliche Probleme am Start waren, wie Krebs oder so. Er konnte halt nur, er konnte Kopfschmerzen lösen, die aber sehr gut. Aber dafür, glaube ich, ist dann auch die Investition hoch und dann wurden die Dinge auch anders verwendet. Es gibt ja oft so Sachen, dass Dinge für irgendwas erfunden wurden, da schlecht waren, aber für andere Sachen gut. Ich glaube zum Beispiel Tesafilm sollte ursprünglich ein Wundpflaster werden, was man auf Wunden klebt und dann mit Wunden verarztet. Und Leute haben gesagt, das ist scheiße, Leute. Und dann haben die gesagt, ja, jetzt haben wir es aber halt schon. Und dann ist die Firma pleite gegangen und dann haben sie so an die Wand geklebt, so out of business, womit sollen wir das jetzt hinkleben und dann ja, wir haben jetzt noch zehn Tonnen Tesafilm rumschieden und dann plötzlich du du du du und das klappt ja richtig gut und dann haben sie das Geschäft direkt wieder aufgemacht. Lustigerweise wurden Post-its erfunden, weil da wollte jemand einen sehr starken Kleber erfinden, hat aber den schwächsten Kleber der Welt erfunden, aber der war genau so schwach, dass es so gerade hält, so gerade hält. Und das war wiederum so gut, weil es hält halt so, das kennt man ja, wenn man ein Post-it irgendwo kleben hat, irgendwann fällt er halt runter, weil der Kleber einfach sauscheiße ist. Ja, aber das ist gut, weil dann oft ist das, was auf dem Post-it draufsteht, auch dann erloschen. So, Zahnarzttermin am Mittwoch. Und dann spätestens Freitag fällt er ab und das ist auch gut, weil dann ist es schon vorbei. Ist auch gut, dass sie dich selber regenerieren so. Und das hat er dann dafür entwickelt. Dann hat er gesagt, nee, nee, das war die ganze Zeit mein Plan, das war die ganze Zeit mein Plan, Jessica, nein, das war die ganze Zeit mein Plan, ich wollte das so. Stell dir vor, du investierst zwei Jahre deines Lebens, versteckst dich im Keller, um den stärksten Kleber der Welt zu bauen, und nach zwei Jahren kommst du an die Oberfläche und Leute, kommt her! Und dann zack und fällt direkt ab. Du, ich bin schon nicht so clever. Ich bin kein guter Kleber, muss man auch mal sagen. Und hast dir jetzt auch so peinlich geblinzelt, weil du im Keller warst und es war so hell draußen, alle dachten, was ein Freak, und dann dachten alle, oh, da hat er Posted dann doch recht gehabt, Justin Posted. Er wusste die ganze Zeit, wie es geht. Aber sollte nicht, glaube ich, auch Ketchup irgendwie Medizin werden und die Leute haben gesagt, ja, es wirkt halt gar nicht, aber es ist sau lecker, können wir es einfach so haben.
Aber ist das nicht Jägermeister, ist das nicht einfach so ein Hustensaft, der nicht funktioniert, aber halt einfach lecker ist? Und dann alle so, bin ich krank? Hier, Jägermeister, so viel! Zack. So, wo man sich heute dann Gras verschreiben lässt, medizinisches Marihuana, ist man damals halt hin und hat sich so eine Pulle-Jägermeister verschreiben lassen. Liegeleiset! Was war das für eine Welt, die da mal irgendeinen Scheiss bekommen hat? Oh, ich hab Asthma, hier, nimm Snickers, okay, danke einfach, random Sachen und dann irgendwie, Leute, das muss aufhören, das ist alles kreuz und quer. Das war halt der eine, das war halt der eine Schamane, der Renni, der Renni rum den Magen auf erfunden hat, aber keine Ahnung hatte, was dachte er, nehmens das Snickers gegen Husten. Ja, oder der so eine unglaublich lecker schmeckende Pastille erstellen wollte und dann hier so Remy durchgegeben hat und dann, Leute, es schmeckt scheusslich, aber mir geht's gut. Diese Vorstellung, dass irgendwie, weiss nicht, damals das Fürstentum Württemberg, alle waren krank, alle hatten furchtbare, die hatten Pocken, die hatten dann die Pest, aber niemand hatte Sodbrennen, niemand. Ja, und sie hatten extrem leckere Medizin, ich sterbe,um, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum, mnum,shaltung, was zu schaffen wirklich, was zu erfinden, war gleich null, beziehungsweise bei ein Prozent. Deswegen hatte auch niemand Erwartungen, weil die Messlatte war extrem niedrig. Niemand wusste, was das Wort Messlatte bedeutet schon. Weißt du, dann haben die halt angefangen zu probieren. Oder Messlatte, je nachdem. Oh, Mildlatte! Oh, das klingt nicht richtig. Und dann haben sie halt angefangen, der eine muss ja immer angefangen haben, eine Kuh zu melken. Und dann kommt Milch raus. Und ich glaube nicht, dass der gedacht hat, das jetzt, was ich mache, wird Erfolg haben. Zum Glück haben wir Zehntausende davon gezüchtet. Jetzt sind die endlich sowas Nütze. Wir probieren mal. Und dann der eine, sorry Joe, was machst du da? Was macht er unter der Kuh? Ich meine, wir haben ja heute Erfinder, wahnsinnig, das sind ja Genius und Genies, die wir bewundern, irgendwie Da Vinci und so. Aber rückblickend, es waren einfach Leute, die langweilig waren, die einfach irgendeinen Scheiss zusammengerührt haben und dann, so, das ist jetzt mein Schokoriegel, äh, es schmeckt scheusslich, aber damit kann man zum Mond fliegen, okay, das ist meine Idee, das war meine Idee, fliegen können damit. Einfach nur Stümper, das waren alles Stümper. Ja, Stümper, auch so ein Nobel, der wird sich da TNT entwickeln, wo man sagt, wow, was will ich jetzt machen, wenn ich mich ins Luft jagen, ho, Nobel. So, mein neuer Beruhigungstee wird heute zum ersten Mal, booo, booo, okay, Füßentum, Württemberg ist weg. Sie haben aber jetzt Hausverbot im Messegelände, aber by the way, lass uns mal ein bisschen was davon kaufen. Ach ja, Mittelalter. Und mittlerweile ist es schwer, was Neues zu erfinden. Die haben alles schon weg erfunden, die ganzen Idioten, und heute sind die Leute viel klüger, aber alles wurde schon erfunden. Vielleicht ist es gar nicht so gut, dass die Menschen heute so klug sind, vielleicht wäre es besser, wenn die so ein bisschen dümmer wären und sich nicht so viele Gedanken machen, sondern einfach mal sagen, Leute, ich mache jetzt einfach eine leckere Suppe und am Ende halt die Krebs. Ich dachte mir, es ist total sinnvoll, so eine Waschmaschine und dann kann man auswählen, zu welcher Wohneinheit man gehört in so einem Mehrfamilienhaus und und klickt dann seinen Namen an, und dann hat man seine Voreinstellungen, die sind gespeichert, und man macht es rein, und am Ende wird die Rechnung für Wasser aufgeteilt. Und man muss nur so viel bezahlen, wie man da diese Waschmaschine benutzt hat. Das ist keine Erfindung, das ist Kommunismus, Stefan. Ja, gut. Aber es klingt nicht schlecht in der Idee. Meine Idee? Hast du bei einer Waschmaschine jemals die Einstellung geändert? Nee. Eine Einstellung auch nicht. That's it. Ja, wirklich. Dieses Rad, dieses Code-Rad mit 20 verschiedenen Einstellungen, einfach so ein bisschen wie beim Glücksrad, dreh einfach und guck, wo es stehen bleibt und dann fuck it, passt schon.
Und dann, ja, hat geklappt, so mache ich es jetzt immer. Ja, ich glaube, solange du nicht irgendwie so ein ganz kleines Shirt rausholst, also richtig kleines, so ein little, little shirt, ich glaube, so lange würde ich auch nichts verändern. Ne, ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, was ich waschen würde, wo ich sage,
ne, das klappt mit den normalen Einstellungen bestimmt nicht. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie sage, nee, nee, nee, nee, das hier, das ist was Besonderes. Mein Kettenhemd wasche ich nicht mit der normalen Waschmaschine. Ja, mal gucken, in der Broschüre nachschlagen, Kettenhemd, K, K, K, K, hmm. Hat das wirklich was gebracht? Ich mein, angenommen, so ein Riesen-Morgenstern wird von der Nazgul auf dich drauf gescheppert, und du hast ein Kettenhemd an. Hilft das dann wirklich, oder stirbst du nur an inneren Blutungen statt an äusseren? Ich glaub, es war primär ein modisches Accessoire eigentlich. Ich glaube, das wurde einfach angezogen, weil es cool aussieht und irgendwann so, Leute, warum tragen wir das alles? Vor allem, stell dir mal vor, so ein Kettenhemd, das besteht ja aus ganz vielen kleinen Metallringen, also unendlich vielen. Und jetzt heißt es, oh scheiße, Lothring greift an, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, schnell, schnell, schnell, Ringe, Ringe, Ringe, Ringe, Ringe, komm, komm, komm, Ringe. Und dann fangen die alle an, diese Kettenhemden zu basteln. Es gab doch bestimmt in jeder mittelalterlichen Schlacht Leute, die hatten nur so ein halbes Kettenhemd an, weil die so ein Bauchfreies. Oder einfach nur so eine Kette, weil nur die erste Reihe wurde fertig und der Gegner hat so gesagt, wow, süss. Weil sie einfach nicht fertig geworden sind und dann hatten sie irgendwie so einen Tanktop, so wie so ein Unterhemd, so einfach so, sorry, bin nicht fertig geworden. Aber meine Arme kann ich besser bewegen, mit mehr Bewegungsfreiheit. Es stimmt schon, es ist ein schmaler Grad zwischen kleinem Kettenhemd und ausladendem Schmuck, weil es gibt ja manchmal so Halbsketten, die so riesengroß sind, so halbe Panzer eigentlich und irgendwann sagt man so, es ist noch zwei Zentimeter mehr und es ist eine Rüstung einfach. Aber allein nicht vorstellen, dass es irgendwann keine Rüstungen gab, und dann irgendwann, wir sind doch im Mittelalter, ist egal, und dann so zwei Armeen aufeinander zugelaufen sind, und man hat den Feind schon kommen sehen, hinten am Berg, und man hat Alarm gerufen, die Feinde kommen, Lothring greift an, und dann hinten kommt ganz langsam der Feind erst näher, und die checken erst dann, dass die Rüstungen erfunden haben und die sich einfach ganz langsam nur auf die zu bewegen und noch so drei Tage brauchen, bis die Armee angekommen ist aus Rittern. Einfach weil die jetzt Rüstungen haben und wahnsinnig lächerlich langsam laufen wie so Michelin-Männchen, weil die sind ja wahnsinnig schwer. Die liegen ja hunderte Kilo. Schreibt mir eine Mail, ob das nicht stimmt. Nee, bitte nicht, Leute, keine Korrekturen. Und vor allem, du denkst dir, ja okay, können wir nicht einfach auch weggehen? Ja, genau. Können wir nicht umziehen, können wir das ganze Dorf... Können wir nicht jetzt da hinziehen, von wo die kommen? Wo die herkommen, ja, lass uns deren Stadt einnehmen. Wir ziehen in deren Häuser. Lass uns deren Frauen und Kinder umbringen. Und jedes zweite Jahr ziehen wir wieder in die andere Stadt zurück und die feindliche Armee bewegt sich immer hin und her, ganz langsam. Ganz langsam. Nomadenvölker, die einfach hin und her ziehen und die so, bleibt hier, bleibt stehen. Ein Vorstellung, bis sie immer das Dorf gewechselt haben, wieder zurück und die wie so ein Pendel immer gegangen sind, bis sie erst umgekippt sind, weil es zu schwer war. Das ist doch scheiße, Leute. Was im Kreis. Ja, ach man, das arme Volk, jetzt tut ein bisschen Mitleid mit Rüstungen. Ja, es stimmt schon. Wir sehen dir nix, wir laufen nur rum, was ist unser Ziel? Waren die Rüstungen vielleicht eine scheiss Idee? Vor allem Rüstungen waren ja auch wahnsinnig teuer. Das konnte man sich ja nur leisten, wenn man irgendwie adlich war oder so. Aber ich stelle mir irgendwie so einen, keine Ahnung, so einen normalen Soldaten vor, der irgendwie gut geplündert hat und so eine Goldmünze hat. Und dann sagt so, fuck it, it's all in und geht dann zum Waffenschmied und sagt, ich hätte gerne Rüstung, ja, eine Goldmünze, das reicht vielleicht für einen Arm. Und dann denkt er sich, soll ich das jetzt machen, ein Arm? Vielleicht, oder? Und er sagt, safety first, safety first, lieber ein Arm als kein Arm. Ja, welchen Arm denn? Ich schreibe mit rechts, aber ich, aber ich masturbiere mit links, ich habe mich noch nicht festgelegt. Aber wenn der Gegner jetzt Rechtshänder ist, dann haut der ja auf mein Link. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, w so ein Schild, erst denken, dann bestellen. Ja, PS, vielleicht erst mal die Hände. PS, wir haben noch den Buchstaben P noch nicht erfunden. War eine verrückte Zeit einfach, war eine verrückte Zeit. Ja, wir machen das, wir machen das mit dem Mittelalter. Die erste Folge dreht sich nur um das Volk, was Rüstung erfunden hat, aber sehr langsam ist. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist nicht schlecht. Und dann steigt man auch so, man steigt so wie in so eine Sitcom ein, so ganz normal dieses Sofa in der Mitte und es ist eine normale Familien-Sitcom, nur alle sind extrem langsam, weil sie immer die Rüstungen haben. Mich seht ihr nie wieder! Klonk, klonk, klonk, okay, Tor hoch, Tor hoch, okay, klonk, klonk. Er macht den Al-Fussmann, aber in schlecht.
Und das Publikum bricht in Gelächter aus und lacht bis in die Renaissance.
Wie bei Seinfeld.
Aber auch so Gaukler im Mittelalter, du kannst ja, jeder kann ja behaupten,
ja, einerseits, auf der anderen Seite, du gehst einmal so nach London, schaust dir da Shakespeare an,
dann gehst du irgendwo, keine Ahnung, nach Frankreich und sagst, ja, das ist nur unsere Idee, Hamlet. Woo, gute Story, wow, Typ bringt seinen Onkel nicht um, crazy, wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen, woo, ja, ist von uns, kann ja niemand nachverfolgen, du kannst dir behaupten, einfach, hättest du geschrieben und im Endeffekt kann dir niemand sagen, nee, das habe ich aber schon mal in London gehört. Man könnte auch seinen Nachbarn einfach umbringen und es würde niemand herausfinden, weil es sowas wie DNA-Tests noch nicht gab, oder Florentin? Glaubst du, man könnte da einfach seinen Nachbarn umbringen und dann gucken? Das ist eine interessante Frage, weil das muss man sich ja als zum Beispiel Pen-and-Paper-Spieler oft fragen, wenn man so ein Abenteuer leitet. Und jetzt kommt ein Spieler, bringt einfach jemanden in der Gasse um und dann denkt man sich was machen die autoritäten jetzt also die es gibt ja keine du kannst ja nur die leute befragen so wer war es und alle sagen ja der dorf jude und dann wird der halt umgebracht so und deshalb auch lame die haben ja keinen also haben die auch so was wie ein bewusstsein dafür dass die jetzt unbedingt diesen mörder fangen müssen und wie machen die das ist es dann nur so weiss kein Mensch. Ich glaube, es weiss wirklich niemand, wie das damals war. Vielleicht schon. Wahrscheinlich schon. Wahrscheinlich weiss man das gut. Sehr gut dokumentiert. In dem gleichen Museum, wo das Eulenbuch stand, war auch so ein tolles Bild, so ein riesiges Bild von so einem ganz, ganz jungen, ähm, jungen Mann, der König geworden ist, zum Kaiser gekrönt wurde, ich weiss nicht mehr, wie er h. Und dann, der Audio-Guide war sehr interessant und war sehr euphorisch auch und hat einem erklärt, was dieser Junge, dass er irgendwie mit 14 schon Kaiser zum Kaiser gekrönt wurde, weil seine Eltern gestorben sind und seine 18 Geschwister sind alle gestorben als Babys und der hat dann einfach das beste Leben, weil er halt mit 14 Kaiser wurde und dann ging der Audio-Guide halt ein bisschen über ihn erzählt. Und der letzte Satz war dann, ja, später erlangte er traurige Berühmtheit, weil er die Hugenottenkriege ausgelöst hat und Millionen Menschen gestorben sind. Ciao, ciao, das war's von mir. Ciao, Audioguide, Audioguide out. Ja, und das fand ich auch so, und er lacht einen so an mit so grossen, braven Augen. Und man denkt so später, du Arschloch, hast du einfach Millionen Menschen umbringen lassen. Schon furchtbar diese Zeit auch. Also allein, du musst ja auch wissen, dass was falsch läuft in deiner Zeit, wenn du als so ein 60 Jahre alter Weiser, Eunuch, plötzlich so einen Zwölfjährigen krönen musst zum Kaiser. Dann musst du doch denken, ist unser System wirklich das Beste? Oder sollte man noch mal nachdenken vielleicht? Einmal mehr nachdenken. Ja, stimmt schon. Schwierige Zeit. Ja, vielleicht noch nicht so gut. Ah, was machst du heute noch so? Wie sieht so ein Tag aus, wenn du ... Hast du heute eine Show, ne? Wo seid ihr gerade? Ja, heute in Berlin. Wir hatten zwei in folge und ich ist tatsächlich ein bisschen schwierig weil ich würde heute gerne nach hamburg fahren aber es ist wieder so ein timing ding ich muss wirklich exakt wenn die show zu ende ist muss ich exakt direkten car to go finden exakt ohne verkehr perfekt zum hauptbahnhof fahren perfekt exakt ohne parkplatz zu suchen sofort einen parkplatz finden sofort aussteigen jede tre, zwei Treppenstufen mit einem Schritt schaffen, dann schaffe ich's gerade noch in den Zug. Wenn ein Element davon nicht stimmt, hab ich verloren. Beim Car-to-Go ist es scheissegal, wo du es abstellst. Das ist mein grosser Tipp. Car-to-Go's gehen immer weg. Vor allem, zweiter Tipp, an Stellen, wo du denkst, hier kann ich niemals parken, weil die überall Menschen sind, weil ich in der Fußgängerzone bin gerade, da gehen die am besten weg, weil da erwartet auch niemand ein Car2go und das sind oft die vollsten Orte. Ich bin mal ganz, ganz spät erst zum Kölner Hauptbahnhof gefahren und mir ging es ähnlich wie dir da und ich habe den einfach mitten in der Fußgängerzone abgestellt und bin dann gegangen und es war bis heute keine Konsequenzen. Du kannst mit dem Car2Go umgehen wie der letzte Mensch. Es stimmt schon, es ist ein kleines Risiko. Einmal habe ich schon einen Strafzettel bekommen, weil das Car2Go abgeschleppt wurde, weil ich im Parkverbot stand. Direkt am Hamburger Hauptbahnhof sogar, wo man eigentlich denkt, da ist enorm viel Umschlag. Aber es ist trügerisch. Das Problem ist halt vor allem, in dem Moment, in dem ich das Car2Go brauche, brauchen auch zweitausend Leute, die gerade die Show gesehen haben, das Car2Go. Und das ist halt unbeständig. Und ich jetzt überlege mir die ganze Zeit, ob sich das Lungen... Ja, er macht heute Abend noch den Mardersong und sagt ganz zwischendurch im Songtext, kannst du sagen, aber bitte, bitte kein Car2Go nach der Show nehmen. Ja, das stimmt. Bitte, bitte, wenn euch der Song gefallen hat. Das Neo Magazin-Publikum, das sind so frech und so frech Trolle, die machen es dann extra, um lustig zu sein. Deswegen, ich weiss es nicht, ob ich nicht vielleicht irgendwie einen sauren Apfel beiße und schon eine Stunde davor das miete. Und dann, ich weiss es nicht genau, ich weiss nicht genau, wie ich das mache, das ist ärgerlich. Aber krieg ich schon. Du führst schon eine Lösung. Heute kommt Matzen. Matzen, wow! Kann man den oder die auch mal persönlich kennenlernen? Ja, schöne Grüße. Ja, ich kenne mich ja überhaupt gar nicht aus mit dieser deutschen Musikkultur irgendwie. Ich auch nicht leider. Vor allem, man ist ja auch mit professionellen Musikern unterwegs, die haben richtig Ahnung davon, was sie machen und die kennen das alles. Und man ist ja so wie so der kleine Bruder, der irgendwie die Mutter gesagt hat, nimm du doch bitte auch mit und er hat keine Ahnung von gar nichts ist dabei und dann auch so ah ok ja stimmt Cis und dann Moldur ja ja vor allem mir geht es auch so mit deutschen Schauspielern ich weiss immer nicht wer das ist was auch problematisch ist an dem in einem gewissen Punkt wenn du dann irgendwie im Catering stehst und die kennen solltest aber ich habe keine Ahnung ich, ich weiss nicht, wer die ganzen Leute sind, ehrlich gesagt. Da muss man sich einfach davon bilden. Ich finde, wir haben da schon auch irgendwie so eine Bringschuld, wir beiden. Also wir können nicht einfach in einer Branche rumtanzen und die Leute nicht kennen. Ich finde, du hast schon auch jetzt, als jemand, der auf der Bühne steht und professionelle Musik macht, das hast du ja nicht ausgesucht, okay, aber das ist jetzt nur mal dein Job, du machst professionelle Musik, ich finde, da muss man ein bisschen was können jetzt und kennen. Du musst wissen, was ein Glissando ist. Du musst wissen, was Crescendo ist. Ja, das weiß ich ja, aber ich kenne halt Matzen nicht, das sind ja auch nochmal unterschiedliche Arten von Wissen über Musik, aber es ist halt... Nein, nein, nein, nein, denn wer hat das Glissando erfunden? Matzen, richtig. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Vor allem, ich habe auch so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, mit den Musikern zu connecten irgendwie, weil ich habe das Gefühl, ich nehme die nicht ernst und ich weiß nicht genau, wie ernst man die nehmen soll, weil das ist ja immer so dieses Ding, so Künstler und sind die dann super krass und ich habe dann einen der Trompetenspieler gefragt, du kannst ja jetzt super gut Trompete spielen, kannst du auch besser eine Trompete nachmachen als normale Leute? Ja. Kein Verständnis. Kein Verständnis. Seitdem ist die Stimmung im Turbus ein bisschen angekratzt. Ich habe neulich einen Podcast gehört und der war nicht so richtig, ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, war das ein sehr bekannter Podcast oder ein sehr unbekannter Podcast und ich habe immer wieder so Schaffelmode angemacht, ich weiß nicht mehr genau. Auf jeden Fall war das Problem an der Folge, dass der Nachbar, der autistische Nachbar, die ganze Zeit Family Gay auf der Trompete gespielt hat. Die ganze Zeit. Gema Strike auch. Die ganze Zeit. Und dann war es vorbei und ... Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da kann darüber nicht so bedingt lachen, weil es halt ein Autist ist, der damit kompensiert. Und man will ihm sagen, ich spiel wenigstens mal einen anderen Song. Aber es ist halt einfach ein Autist, der braucht die Gewohnheit. Naja, die ganze Zeit Family Guy. Ach, grossartig. Falls du die Folge findest, schick sie mir. Ich find das fantastisch. Man kann sich manchmal nicht aussuchen, wo man einen Podcast aufnimmt. Ich glaube, es war ein Podcast, wo ... Ja, warte, ich find's raus. Wo der Comedian Rory Scovel, von dem ich großer Fan bin, zu Gast war. Vielleicht ist das auch ein Witz von denen, aber nee, die haben ja ernsthaft darüber geredet. Ein Comedian, den ich auch gesehen habe, der ist live in Amsterdam. Weil Tarkan Baci, unser netter Autor und Kollege und ich, wir sind zusammen hingefahren, weil immer coole Comedians in Amsterdam sind und Robbie Scobel kennt halt niemand. Und ich habe mich ein bisschen gewundert, warum er in Amsterdam ist, weil der hat hier bestimmt kein Publikum und hat er auch nicht. Er war einfach befreundet mit so einem Barbesitzer und hat in so einer ganz kleinen Comedybar in Amsterdam, hat er dann anderthalb Stunden eine Show gemacht und hat mit allen gesprochen und so, das war richtig cool, kann ich also nur empfehlen und unbedingt sein Stand-Up anschauen, von dem wir beide große Fans sind. Aber jetzt kommen ja auch ... ... Stand-Up for the first time. Ja, auf Netflix zu sehen, fantastisch. Jetzt kommen aber auch viele Komis nach Deutschland, ne? Also zwei, Bill Burr, jetzt Daniel Sloss kommt auch bei. Ja, und lustigerweise, ja, und man muss sagen, ich hab Daniel Sloss nach Deutschland geholt. Das ist wirklich wahr, weil ich hab seine Mutter angeschrieben. Ich hab die Mutter von Daniel Sloss, weil er erzählt in seinem Stand-Up bei Netflix auch von seiner Mutter, die UN-Botschafterin für Klimaschutz ist. Und die ist sehr aktiv bei Twitter und ich fand das sehr lustig, weil die soll wahnsinnig lustig sein, hat er im Stand-Up erzählt und ich folge der halt bei Twitter und sie ist halt einfach eine proud Mom, die andauernd über ihren Sohn twittert und ich dachte mir, wenn ich jetzt ihn anschreibe, um zu fragen, ob wir mal nach Deutschland kommen, will er es wahrscheinlich nicht lesen, aber seine Mutter wird es auf jeden Fall lesen, weil die hat zwölf Follower. Also da habe ich seine Mutter angeschrieben, ob Daniel vielleicht mehr Lust hat, nach Deutschland zu kommen, was ein bisschen seltsam ist, weil meine ausgeregte Mutter fragt und dann hat sie gesagt, nee, ist nicht geplant, aber dann habe ich mit ihr ein bisschen geschrieben und dann hat sie mir eine E-Mail-Adresse genannt und das habe ich dann unserer Agentur gegeben, die auch schon Bill Burr nach Deutschland geholt hat. Und jetzt kommt Ende des Jahres Daniel Slaus nach Deutschland, weil seine Mutter auf Twitter aktiv ist. Alter. Muss man sagen. Das war eine sehr lustige Geschichte. Und zur Show kommen vier Leute. Oder nächste Jahr, sorry. Nee, alle Podcast-Ufo-Zuhörer schauen sich verdammt nochmal Daniel Sloss an. Lass uns gut dastehen. Daniel Sloss, The Sloss. Als Comedy-Standort Deutschland. Wir freuen uns sehr und wir hoffen, dass er vielleicht sogar mal irgendwann in Podcast-Ufo, vielleicht mal für, sei es für fünf Minuten oder so zu Gast wäre. Das wäre natürlich toll. Wer weiß. Freuen wir uns sehr. Tolles Donnerstag, soll er rausgehauen auf Netflix. Nur zu empfehlen. Wie geht's dir sonst so? Was ist morgen? Ist morgen wieder eine Show? Wie viele Shows habt ihr jetzt schon am Start gehabt? Ich habe den Überblick verloren. Morgen ist Hamburg, es ist einfach, man weiß auch nicht genau wo, es ist ja immer so ein bisschen, das ist ja das Tolle an dem Jan-Bürmermannschen Stil der Ironie, wo es völlig erwartbar ist, dass du auf eine Bühne gehst in, sagen wir mal, Köln und dann sagst Hallo Bottrop und alle, ha ha ha ha. Aber das ist wirklich einfach keine Ahnung, wo man ist. Aber man hat wirklich einfach keine Ahnung, wo man ist. Man wacht auf in einer anderen Stadt und es schneit plötzlich irgendwie und es gibt plötzlich drei Sonnen und so, okay, wo bin ich jetzt? Und auch scheißegal einfach, weil du lebst einfach nur von einem Raum zum anderen. Es ist wirklich merkwürdig, das ist wie wenn du geboren wirst und du wirst in den neuen Mutterleib reingeboren. So, du bist in einem Tourbus, wachst auf und du wirst geboren und du bist zwei... Und es ist wahnsinnig feucht und Leute streiten und der ganze Alkoholgeduft. Und zwei Sekunden bist du am hellen Tageslicht und bist du im nächsten Mutterleib und bist wieder in der Location und gehst nicht aus dem Haus. Aber wie muss ich dir das vorstellen, weil du bist ja sehr, also im positivsten Sinne antisozial. Du redest nicht gerne mit Menschen und du bist an dem richtigen Punkt ziehst du dich dann gerne auch zurück. Vor allem wenn es nach der Show noch darum geht, mal ein Bierchen zu trinken oder sowas. Und das geht ja nicht bei einem Tourbus, oder geht das doch?
Schwierig. Ist das nicht das
schlimmste Leben, was du dir gerade vorstellen kannst?
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen problematisch.
Es gab so zwei Busse, es gab den Partybus
und den Chilloutbus und ich bin den Chilloutbus
gegangen mit der Hoffnung, dass ich
immer direkt nach der Show schlafen
kann, aber jetzt haben sich die so ein bisschen vermischt
und jetzt ist es immer so ein bisschen schwer und du denkst
dir, du liegst halt so im Bett und unten ist Party, also der ist doppeldecker, oh doppeldecker, ja und oben sind die Betten und unten ist Party und du liegst halt da oben alleine und denkst dir, kann ich jetzt wirklich in Eric-Andre-T-Shirt und Unterhose da runterlaufen und sagen, hey Leute, könnt ihr bitte leise sein, nein, kannst du nicht und dann liegst du halt da, keine Ahnung, träumst irgendwas im Halbschlaf und das ist merkwürdig. Aber ganz wichtig, immer die ganze Location nutzen. Ganz wichtig, wenn ihr auch mal auf einer Tour seid, denkt nicht, dass ihr nur auf dem Tourbus und den Backstage beschränkt seid. Die ganze Location nutzen. Schaut euch mal um, wo ist das Foyer, wo sind denn sowas wie Büroräume, die vielleicht leer sind. Oft sind so Locations riesengroß und man muss einfach nur genau wissen, wo man hinkann und dann hat man ganz viel Räume, um sich irgendwo anders hin zu bewegen. Ja, das wird auch ein Relatable-Tipp. Ja, und ich lese gerade die, ich weiß nicht, ob die neu sind, aber grosse Empfehlung die Reklam-Sachbuch-Reihe. Reklam kennt ja jeder, die kleinen gelben, dann gibt es noch die roten, das sind die mit Englisch oder Originalsprache, dann die blauen Lektüreschlüssel. Und dann, ich weiß nicht, ob die neu sind, aber es gibt jetzt die lila, lila, pink und das sind Sachbücher. Und das sind Sachbücher und dann gibt es dann ein Reklambüchlein für ein Thema. Es gibt dann irgendwie Quantentheorie, das Gehirn, Mathematik und sowas. Und dann hast du ein so ein Büchlein, wo alles drinsteht, was man müssen muss. Und die kann man sich einfach für zehn Euro, kannst du ja fünf Stück davon kaufen, schön durchlesen, weiss eigentlich alles. Und die sind gutgeschrieben. Nein, die kosten mehr. Sechs Euro kostet es pro Buch. Ja, so je nachdem. Das Gehirnbuch ist sehr dünn, weil ich meine... Man weiss nicht so viel darüber.
Ja, wer liest das Buch denn? Das Gehirn. Da kannst du ja auch in den Spiegel gucken.
Evolution, eine Einführung. Das klingt nach etwas, was ich dringend mal für den Podcast lesen sollte.
Ja, grundsätzlich.
Brian und Deborah Charlesworth, Evolution, eine Einführung.
Ich habe jetzt gelesen, Quantentheorie und Relativitätstheorie.
Sehr spannend, sehr, sehr spannend.
Obwohl ich nur die Hälfte verstehe, aber es ist trotzdem spannend.
Ja, Quantentheorie ist natürlich Quantenmechanik nicht so einfach.
Na ja, dazu noch mehr.
Wir machen noch einen speziellen Podcast drüber, machen wir nächste Woche.
Ja genau, das war der Relatable Tour Podcast.
Wie müsst ihr euch auf Tour vorstellen, wo müsst ihr euch einstellen?
Und das war unser How-To.
Ja, falls ihr da keinen Bock drauf habt, dann skippt einfach die nächsten beiden Folgen, weil ich bin noch zwei weitere Wochen auf Tour.
On the Road, vielleicht machen wir mal eine Folge direkt von der Bühne oder vielleicht kann ich ein paar Musiker interviewen oder vielleicht, keine Ahnung, wer sonst noch zu Gast ist, Bono oder Kurt Krömer mal schauen.
Bono?
Bono.
Tatsächlich dachte ich auch, es heisst Placebo.
Ja, Placebo. Aber es heisst nicht Placebo. Wie Edinburgh, Edinburgh, Placeboro. Bitte keine Korrekturen schicken und ansonsten viel Spaß, wir sind in Berlin nicht abgehoben, deswegen müssen wir das jetzt nachholen. Zweimal abheben. Naja, du bist ja noch in Berlin.
Das stimmt, tatsächlich, ich bin eigentlich nie offiziell abgehoben.
Und vielen Dank an Michael für das fantastische Intro.
Vielen Dank an alle, die weiterhin Intros schicken.
Wir sind jetzt mittlerweile an einem Punkt, wo die Guten kommen.
Also nichts gegen die Intros, die bis jetzt kamen, wir hatten schon fantastische Intros, aber die werden immer besser.
Und seid sehr gespannt auf die nächsten Folgen,
auf die tollen Intros, die noch folgen.
Cool.
Das freut mich auch sehr.
Das war Stefan Tietze.
Vielen Dank, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast, das, was Thorntin will.
Haut rein.
Und ich wünsche noch viel Spaß oder Abend,
Rock Berlin für mich, ein zweites Mal.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, macht's gut, ciao.